pour le groupe
UMP merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président Mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues ma
question sadressé à Madame marieol
Touren mais je crois que c'est madame
delonet qui m'apportera des réponses
donc madame la ministre le sujet de la
fin de vie parce qu'il concerne sa
propre mort comme celle des autres est
toujours très difficile à aborder ayons
pleine conscience que la société
contemporaine est plus porté à refuser
l'inéluctable qu'à l'accepter ce sujet
divise la société
essentiellement sur la question de
l'euthanasie et justement le Comité
consultatif national d'éthique vient de
rendre l'avis 121 tout en nuance et
respectueux de la loi Leonetti de 2005
dont j'ai eu l'honneur d'être le
rapporteur ici au Sénat il a été saisi
par le Président de la République après
un premier rapport sur le sujet celui de
Didier scar de décembre
2012 très légitimement on peut se
demander si la loi Leonetti ne renferme
pas déjà quasiment toutes les solutions
sauf à vouloir passer du laisser mourir
au faire mourir faute d'avoir été mal
expliqué la loi Leonetti est mal
appliquée le rapport SICAR l'a
clairement dit le Comité consultatif
national d'éthique aussi doutant
d'ailleurs de l'intérêt d'une nouvelle
loi soit l'avis 121 préconise la
nécessité de l'améliorer concernant les
directives anticipées la procédure
collégiale et la sédation en phase
terminale remarquons cependant que cette
dernière est dans le prolongement de ce
que propose la loi actuelle rarement
mise en œuvre il est vrai une large
majorité du Comité s'est dégagé pour
refuser l'assistance au suicide mettant
en exerg les diverses les dérives
observées dans les pays où elle est
légalisée il soulligne également l'accès
encore insuffisant aux soins palliatifs
malgré tout ce qui a été fait ces
dernières années le professeur
Jean-Claude amamezen président du Comité
national d'éthique souhaite un débat à
l'automne estimant indispensable que la
société entière puisse réfléchir comme
nous l'avions d'ailleurs nous-même
proposé le président de la République
l'accepte mais promet un projet de loi à
la fin de cette année visant à compléter
la loi Léonetti n'est-ce pas cependant
relancer un débat clivant pour la
société au moment même où celui du
mariage pour tous laissera pour
longtemps des traces et au moment où
nous avons cru que le gouvernement
allait enfin se concentrer sur les
graves problèmes économiques qui
affaiblissent notre pays et sappent sa
cohésion pourquoi dans l'immédiat ne pas
mettre en œuvre une vraie pédagogie de
la loi mal connue des soignants comme du
public cela demandera déjà beaucoup de
temps et d'énergie mais c'est essentiel
alors madame la ministre que
comptez-vous faire pour y remédier très
bien merci Madame Michel de laonet
ministre chargé des personnes âgées de
l'autonomie monsieur le Président méames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur de Rio je vous prie tout
d'abord de bien vouloir excuser madame
Touren qui est en ce moment même comme
vous le savez à Matignon avec les
partenaires sociaux sur la question des
retraites je vous transmets donc sa
réponse à la suite du rapport sur la fin
de vie que lui a remis le professeur si
car en décembre dernier le président de
la République a saisi en effet le Comité
national d'éthique de trois questions
concernant l'éventuelle évolution de la
loi d'olti ces questions portent sur les
directives anticipé de fin de vie et
spécifiquement les conditions de leur
recueil et de leur application
lorsqu'elles serait émise par une
personne en pleine santé ou à l'annonce
d'une maladie grave 2è point sur la
façon de rendre plus digne les derniers
moments d'un patient dont les
traitements ont été interrompus à la
suite d'une décision prise à la demande
de la personne de sa famille ou encore
par des soignants troisièmement sur les
modalités et conditions strictes pour
permettre à un malade conscient et
autonôme intin d'une maladie grave et
incurable d'être accompagné et assisté
dans sa volonté de mettre lui-même un
terme à sa vie le Comité national
d'éthique qui a rendu son avis le lundi
1er juillet illustre la difficulté de la
question le président de la République a
pris acte du constat unanime selon
laquelle la loi Leonetti est
insuffisamment approprié et l'accès aux
soins
palliatifs insuff suffisamment connu et
appliqué malgré le déploiement dont ils
ont fait l'objet ces dernières années il
a également pris acte du constat du
Comité consultatif national selon lequel
les soins piatif bien que fondamentaux
ne permettent pas de répondre à toutes
les situations de souffrance et qu'un
débat sur la question de fin de vie est
souhaitable c'est la démarche dans
laquelle
se situe aujourd'hui le président de la
République et au terme de Cees débat un
projet de loi sera proposé afin de
compléter la loi Leonetti merci